i don't even know that's a short one
here because we're almost done doing the
show
pete davidson says he's removing all his
tattoos
pete davidson is happy
[Laughter]
hold on with a what
okay can i say that yes yes can i say it
i hope he gets it removed
like kyle from sons of anarchy okay well
that's okay that's fine
good uh the saturday night live star 27
revealed during a virtual q a
for his film the king of staten island
which i guess is still
out i guess that he is in the process of
removing his ink
film clinic critic mike mcgragan
from aisle seats attended the event and
shared the news
when someone asked uh if mcgregor if he
was serious he replied that he was
uh real adding that davidson even showed
his hand which is already done he said
it takes
three to four hours in a makeup chair to
cover them so he figured it would be
easier to get them burned off
we've been saying that and you remember
we've been saying the problem with
with pete davidson on snl besides that
he's not funny is that he can't really
play any characters
all of his characters have hand tattoos
and i guarantee
you that was something that was probably
something lauren michael says
you got to get those hand tattoos
removed all right can we do this then
i need everybody to get on is he still
on instagram or did he stay off there
after that
after he cried pete i don't know i'm no
[ __ ] does he have social media somebody
find pete davidson's social media
everyone needs to bombard him and be
like
wow so like that ruth bader ginsburg
those hillary tats those were completely
meaningless to you then yeah
that's everybody needs to bombard him
with well so pretty much all your ink
was meaningless so
so you're fake so everything about you
is fake
and then people people have been
tweeting uh for example
uh dally shamrick says losing sleep over
pete davis and saying he's getting rid
of his tattoos
uh jenna jenna de zuna
says pete davidson is apparently
getting his tattoos all removed so if
you see me crying tonight
mind your own business that's why
that's why he's crying uh dave she's
crying
davidson is known for his tattoos
definitely not his comedy
which has been inspired by love's uh
politicians
hillary clinton tv game of thrones and
films harry potter
listen to the tattoos he has in 2018 he
had removed
he had more than 40 including one
covering up his ex ariana grande's name
the top part of davidson's left sleeve
is an homage to his father a firefighter
who
died on please guilt him into not
covering up his tattoos that's what i
want to see now
davidson has spoken a lot about his ink
saying it's part of his coping with his
mental health struggles
he's a woman every time we talk about
him too and every time these things get
clipped there's always these [ __ ]
davidson simps
that come out not just women because you
think it would just be women there's
guys too
that defend this [ __ ] guy whatever
happened to gary cooper
no seriously though like the whole
[ __ ] this this
if you were if you were a man and you
were constantly being like my mental
health struggles
like back in the day bro you would have
been ruthlessly picked apart by your guy
friends like they would have been like
mental health oh you're gonna kill
yourself you're gonna cry
like that's how guys are if you're
constantly going
and especially when you start blaming it
for every single one of your problems
and your bad tattoos and like
like i'm sorry man but like your poor
impulse control
and your inability to commit yourself to
any sort of level of self-improvement
is not you can't just dismiss that as my
mental health struggles
my tr my truth and my story he's a woman
like you said
including his diagnosis with borderline
personality disorder after years of
battling depression and anxiety
he said i cut my chest that's why i
started getting tats on my chest to
cover them
it's just a release if you can't get a
tattoo
when i'm so manic and upset sometimes
that's the only thing that'll work for
me
he's a girl who wants attention smoke
weed and play video games you [ __ ]
right like that's what i would do
in the interview he added that rehab he
saw treatment at sierra tuscan
treatment center in arizona over the
holidays last year taught him healthier
ways to cope
like listening to music or taking a cold
shower which has helped him recover
[ __ ] the worst
i i hate pete davidson with a with
a burning passion he's the absolute
worst